thank you for your patience and moving
to a new area
we needed to make sure that we had more
room in the warehouse to continue
cleanup and all that so thank you very
much for your patience and moving to a
new spot
the bulk of the ballots mail ballots are
in the system now
we will have small numbers of mail
ballots that continue
that need to be counted through thursday
that relate to the cures
which deadline ends on thursday november
12th
the id required the deadline was last
friday
we received several thousand emails that
have to manually be gone through to
verify that
the id was provided on those voters so
we're still working on those
and those will continue to flow through
the system as of this morning
the count on the outstanding cures is
still just a bit under 2
000 so we haven't seen a lot of activity
on that
since the last report everybody should
be aware
that starting tomorrow or actually today
excuse me
there will only be one report a day
there's no
large number of mail ballots that are
going in in the afternoon so
every morning by 10 a.m we'll have a new
report out on anything that's updated as
far as the turnout
uh provisional update we have sent our
report to the secretary so there is work
beginning on getting those
uh prepared to be put into the system
and u.s
mail this morning we've got 24 ballots
tomorrow will be the last day
for us to accept anything through the us
mail
and with that i'll turn it over to you
all for questions
the provisional account has not changed
it's still at about 60 000. so staff is
working through on those and now that
we're working with the secretary soon we
should start to be able to put those
into the system
the other ones i can't i can't give you
a number on the cures or the id we're
working through them but they're very
small numbers
can you can you give us a time frame on
how long the provisional valid process
has taken in the past sending out the
secretary of state's office having them
review it
send it back to you guys i don't really
have a benchmark
here in clark county because we've never
had that many provisional ballots
normally it's uh in the thousands and
now it's in the
tens of thousands so we have until
thursday to get that all into the system
is required by ab4
we're hoping that we can start to get
those in uh soon
but i can't really tell you how long
it's about all about the match about
returns from the secretary and them
letting us know that we're clear to move
forward
but we'll definitely be done by thursday
yes
in terms of the automatic signature
verification do you have an idea
as to how many ballots were rejected at
least temporarily because their
signature did not match up
and comparing that to 2016 you have a
rough estimate of that
in 2016 we didn't have the agilis system
so it there's kind of oranges and apples
there on that
the last data that we ran it's been a
while but we were
running through it about 30 on
signatures that were verified
through the agility system so that means
that roughly 70
of signatures were manually being
checked by staff
joe an affidavit is circulating around
right now
on social media um aaron ford says he
hasn't gotten official complaints about
it but
it's apparent whistleblower from i
believe it was the east las vegas
community center
one of your poll workers saying that
they um
had seen had complaints about the
ballots that they were forced to process
and were told to proceed
process it anyway and they also said
that there was about harvesting
happening
in the parking lot from the biden
campaign have you seen this affidavit
and do you have any comments on what the
nbgop is trying to
press there i can't link anything as far
as the affidavit to east las vegas
i i don't know where that came from and
i haven't seen anything related to east
las vegas
we have received that affidavit it is
being reviewed
um i believe that uh pio has put out
some statements on that in response to
it so
my statement would be the same as what
has already been released
um as far as the other one i have no no
knowledge of anything related to
any ballot drop-offs by any any
particular vehicle so
ballot drop-offs were available
throughout the valley there were several
groups who were participating in
gathering ballots and bringing them in
a authorized that so there's really no
issue with groups bringing in those
ballots as long as it's to an authorized
drop-off location
are you concerned that this that this is
coming from within your own workforce
an apparent co-worker no i am not we've
had answers for everything that has
brought
been brought forward and the pio has
released that information to the press
we've had answers for every allegation
that's been brought forward so no i'm
not concerned
in the middle can you tell us how many
mail-in ballots were reported today and
how many left
are left to be released well i've
already done that
but in this report this morning i don't
have that number off top my head but
from yesterday's last report it was in
the thousands uh the new report today
not tens of thousands thousands but we
can get that information off of the
website what was the second half of your
question
how many mail and ballots are left to be
counted it's the cures
so anybody that cures through thursday
and then those
ids that were required the deadline was
friday
many people sent responses into that
it's a manual process of going through
checking the email
printing out the id so that we can get
that ballot counted small numbers it'll
be in the thousands at the most
clark county uh district c race
no there's no way for me to report on
precinct specific
uh the ballots that are i do not
mr ball is it too soon to ask
if ab4 was a success
and would you advocate for using the
same sort of
male a widespread mail process
with even outside a pandemic
i think you're going to be very
disappointed with my answer i think i've
mentioned in previous press conferences
i don't make policy i administrate
elections so whether or not it's been a
success
would be something you'd want to ask
your legislature
they're the ones who put through the
bill we simply act on it
and do what's required by a lot of
process votes so i really don't have any
other comment other than that
in the back joe you know there's been a
lot of questions about signature
verification i'm sure you saw the
pictures of ballots piling up in
mailboxes
if someone found like nine ballots in
their apartment complex
and they signed them with their
handwriting how many of those ballots do
you think would have been
i'm not completely aware of exactly what
you're talking about as far as pictures
i have not seen any pictures of large uh
pictures of ballots and apartment
complexes in the trash on the side of
the road i have not
all right so there have been okay so if
someone found
say nine miles to their apartment
complex and just signed the person's
name with their handwriting
number one they'd be breaking the law
that's a felony
you shouldn't be voting anybody but your
own ballot and if they came through we
would still have the signature match to
rely on for identity are you confident
that the signature
i'm confident that the process has been
working throughout this process yes
in the front there's been uh many claims
by president trump and the gop
of election fraud what can you say to
ensure that the uh
the public can be sure that this is a
fair election
i can say that we've had responses to
any of the allegations that have been
put
through again the pio has been doing an
excellent job of sending out updates on
that information
we will look into anything we have sent
information to the secretary of state
they have an investigative team
they are currently looking into quite a
few things
for those folks in the general public uh
we have the data so if there's anything
that's been done
illegally unfortunately we're gonna
we're gonna find it and the secretary
i'm certain
is going to be vigorously going after
anybody who tried to test the system so
yes they should have confidence in our
voting system
right there i i know that you've
mentioned in the past that the agility
system
has really been a game changer for you
all in trying to
get through as many ballots as possible
i was wondering if you could
speak to you know how working with that
system has been
calibrating it you know to meet your
standards just
what all that has been like at this
point well we worked directly with the
vendor around several tests and getting
into the election as far as i'm
concerned we couldn't have done what we
did this election without that we had
the pandemic to worry about
so hiring large numbers of people and
finding enough space for them to work
safely in social distance would have
been a
tremendous challenge so by running it
through the agilis system which
automated much of our process
and getting things into batches and
checking uh for signatures 30
of those signatures were a match by the
system which took a burden off of my
staff so the agilis was a big difference
in
making sure that we were able we had
assistance from the secretary of state
to bring that in
um we couldn't have done it without that
automated process and if we move into a
situation where we're doing
large numbers of mail ballots in the
future we'll be looking to enhance that
system as well
there was a question over here
there were all sorts of things out there
like people who were on the voter rolls
that were deceased
there's been several issues i'm
confident that
in each of those issues and working with
my po we've released responses on that
there's too many of them at this point
for me to address them all
but there hasn't been an allegation put
forth but we haven't
submitted information to the secretary
so that they could look into it or that
has not been addressed by my pio
you mentioned this agility system was
was implemented after 2016.
so how accurate would you say that this
system is is it possible that it could
be flawed and
there might be problems for this
election we don't have any indication
that that is the case then it was
2 16 is a long time ago it was
implemented this year
we began using it in the primary so
i don't have any reason to believe that
it's not functioning properly
there one more question um you've
mentioned the past couple of days
how hard your staff has worked to pull
all of this off
but there with all of these allegations
that are out there they in effect
call into question the integrity of this
office
you and your staff i was wondering if
you just had to say
anything on that for those people who
are questioning
questioning the integrity of this whole
process my staff leaves those responses
to me
they've been very dedicated in the work
and in fact have received a second win
as a result of the challenges because
they work with this every day
and are very familiar with our processes
and confident that we're doing
and being fair to every member of the
voting community in clark county so i
haven't had any challenges in dealing
with my staff
they're doing an excellent job continue
and as i say they seem to have a pep in
their step because they know that we're
getting close to the end here
and as far as i'm concerned they've done
an extraordinary job this year we're not
done yet
but if it hadn't been for them we
wouldn't have made it
mr gloria are you able to describe for
us
if you've had any security incidents or
situations involving your staff or the
process
i think you're all aware that we've had
quite a bit of activity here at the
election department
i've mentioned on several occasions that
as a result of leadership
in the county and i'm talking
specifically about
our commissioners our chairwoman our
county manager
they've all done an excellent job of
making sure that
sheriff joe lombardo personally called
me to make sure that we were comfortable
with what was going on as far as the
coverage
our park police north las vegas police
department
they've all done an excellent job of
making sure that my staff can feel
secure in this building
they make sure that we have an
opportunity to leave the building safely
so i i think yeah there has been some
things that we're concerned about but
the
coverage that we're getting from law
enforcement has been outstanding and my
staff feels safe here
in the middle can you tell us if any
local candidates have asked for a
recount and if so when would that
process i have none
they they can't make that until after
the canvas and then they have a period
of time in order to submit that
and then they'll have to uh will have to
generate a cost for exactly what it'll
be to run that through the system again
and they'll have to pay prior to us
moving forward with a recount but we're
expecting
that somebody might there are some close
races so we'll be prepared to do it and
you'll find very clearly that it
indicates that all of our accounting has
been correct
so just to clarify when would you expect
the votes to be
served monday november 16th 1pm
clark county commission
there's a chambers job during this
election and you have no problem with
them
how about those voters their challenge
and the question about
the charity or they are asking those do
you have any comments to them
i i believe your question was do i have
any comments for the citizens who have
written in
uh with uh situations that we needed to
deal
to with election internationally and
also to have those issues
and did you hear anything or when they
challenged about whether it's a
wonderful english in this election
and what is their uh mike again
you've kind of put a very broad-based
question out there as far as the general
public and their interaction with the
department we've done everything we can
when they reach us
at the counter or on the phone to answer
their questions on any confusion i think
a lot of the questions are coming from
bogus calls that are going out from some
groups in the community stating to the
voters that the vote has not been
counted
and then they're trying to go through
and verify and expecting to see
vote history posted on their record and
i mentioned on many occasions in these
press conferences that vote history will
not be posted
until after the election the only thing
that ballot tracks in my system can tell
a voter is that we've received their
ballot
as far as challenges again everything
has been brought to our attention my pio
has been on top of it
uh they're reporting on giving responses
to the media he's put out
regular updates throughout the day to
answer a lot of those questions and i
stand with him
we are finding explanations for every
um challenge that they bring up any
questions that they have related to the
integrity of what we're doing we have a
response
all we want to do is count votes all we
want to do is count votes
right there along the lines of your last
answer when you said that
the the voter history won't show up
until after the election
how long is that time frame because i
know there's a lot of folks out there
still wondering
if their ballot has been counted and
they're just kind of waiting in limbo
well not in limbo that process has not
changed we
we've made it clear exactly when that'll
go out there and it's been the same for
many years so
it's an electronic process that we start
to roll up there we've had excellent
turnout it's going to be nearly 80
when we're all done so it takes time to
get those records up
uh we'll have our vote history posted
and then we'll get it to the secretary
of state so sometime shortly after the
canvas we should be able to get the
information updated
right there so your office is
investigating two cases
not my office we don't have an
investigator or a team we've provided
information to the secretary who has
investigators
but go ahead do you believe there are
actually
thousands of those cases of the gop how
would i know that there's no way for me
to know
how does your office or you know how do
you
um catch those fraudulent votes if they
are you know indeed
happening when they report reported to
us any serious allegations brought to
this office is always taken seriously
and we forward the information because
we have it
and goes up to the secretary if we find
somebody who's broken the law
they'll be vigorously going after those
people and there will be penalties
and possibly jail time
that's it thank you very much folks we
appreciate you